so
what is a marriage with gravity
all right so if uh you come out here
and you hold that end up
in your you're offering some resistance
right
you get it you feel that okay you're
lifting that
is some resistance to me pushing down
okay
um and when we are doing our
showmance booty a lot of us
are trying to uh put weight on this
you do feel some increase right there's
some increase
and you could see if we if we put more
uh
weight on this and we'll bend our knees
to do it
it got a little heavier you see but at a
certain point it gets counterproductive
you see so you'll feel original some
heaviness
and then it's starting to get light you
see
and that's what we think is going on in
childhood
so i come up and then
i dropped my weight and you see some
people really exaggerated
you see and it's becoming like a
quadricep
exercise and though that's the benefit
of it you're making your legs stronger
um but this is this is all external
it's all external i lower my body mass
and i'll get some force on that on the
cut
okay uh and going up
is just a resetting or an indexing
of that so i go up
and then down
but everything should be done internally
and if i want to make my legs stronger
i should squat
so what i'm going to do instead is i
have
two
four centers one is at the top when the
sword is trying to change direction
there's energy
and i'm going to send that energy
through me
down into the ground and the other one
is when the sword hits its position at
the end
boom and i'm going to send that force
into my body too and i'm kind of like
playing
[Music]
between these two ground vectors
so as opposed to be going up
and down you're going to see
a force vectoring at the top and then
it'll look
exactly like the one at the bottom
which allows for that kind of bouncing
the sword is just
bouncing back and forth between the two
and i'm just riding the sword my hands
are just riding the sword
and the other one
very difficult to have it be
spring-loaded
at the top and bottom so
what is important is to get away from
the external
is that you stop doing the external
don't drop your center
even three inches
you'll feel stop relying on this
maybe i'll stumble across the ground
vector
okay top one
is harder to get because our minds are
like
i'm going up i'm coming up but there's
actually as i'm trying to reverse it
there's energy or that's not even
correct
i'm reversing it through that pulse
i'm kind of co-q projecting the sword
in the other direction so as it's coming
up
boom i stop it there with the coq
projection
it goes back down boom
back up pop
back down and
in between i have to have a
yielding so it's maybe like tennis
nothing's happening to the ball as it's
flying to the other
racket where its strings are
going to load it be loaded by the wall
and then back comes the ball so if i
remain
tense in between i can't do it
okay it's boom
project down relax just let the ball fly
boom project
okay okay if i hold tension
it's like i'm pushing the ball with the
tennis racquet still attached to it
okay all right